wir gehen jetzt in die ukraine wie
versprochen nach kiew zu unserem bild
reporter paul ronzheimer der dort heute
an einem tag der ausgangssperre
unterwegs sein kann ja sie sehen selbst
mit den klitschko brüder mit vitali dem
kiews bürgermeister und sein bruder
vladimir paul peter du
ja schon am mittag in berlin ich bin
hier mit vitali und wladimir klitschko
wieder die heute ist ausgangssperre in
kiew 36 stunden wie ist die situation
die situation ist kontrolliert die
ausgangssperre hat
militär gegeben und deswegen wie wickie
musik bereits die menschen tief und
deswegen bis morgen 7 noch für uns ganze
stunde wird das funktionieren
danach sehen wie die gasse personen in
stadt wahrscheinlich kommt hoffen wir
dass wird bisschen leichter für da wo
wir haben den letzten tagen viele
angriffe gesehen ob wohnhäuser
zivilisten sind gestorben journalisten
sind gestorben in der ganzen ukraine
tobt der krieg wie viel hoffnung hast du
noch dass es irgendwie einen schnellen
frieden geben kann in der ukraine
das nicht und würde ganz gewählt muss
eine riesige druck machen an russen ja
und die entscheidung trifft jemand im
kreml in moskau
was von unsere kraft abhängt wir machen
alles und verständig auch
einige soldaten
geben eine scharfe antwort für hier
besser lade mir wir haben gestern dem
besuch gesehen der premierminister von
polen in tschechien unter an ihr habt
gefordert dass der papst kommen soll
dass die religiösen an vorkommen soll
nach kehrt was ist mit dem deutschen
bundeskanzler oder von dem französischen
staatspräsidenten wer das eine gute idee
wenn jeden tag ein staatspräsident
regierungschefs käme jede idee ist gut
die umgesetzt wird um diesen krieg zu
stoppen wir müssen jetzt agieren
willkürlich lang gewartet es ist gut
dass kreuzes hier ist gutes die
offiziellen die gestern sieht getroffen
haben ich hier statt tiefen hauptstadt
der ukraine ist es gutes immer wieder
diese internationale druck auf
migration kommt weil jede geschäft der -
und gerade gemacht werden die gelder was
man bekommt wird für waffen verwendet
die waffentypen unsere zivilisten
zerstören unsere infrastruktur deswegen
diese isolation wirtschaftliche
situation ist ganz wichtig gegen uns
druck auszuüben und es genauso wichtig
dass ob das eine mögliche seite
politische seite jede seite und diese
güte stoppen eine präsenz an starken
block gegen russland ist irgendwie was
sich viele menschen fragen wie halten
die ukraine das aus jeden tag neue
angriffe wie haltet ihr das aus wir
halten die menschen das aus mit diesem
druck umzugehen zum beispiel die
vergessene angriffe als apartments an
wohnhäusern zivilisten nach birma
angriff bekam menschen gesprochen wir
sind gebiete zu evakuieren
nach rheine die menschen ich war richtig
überrascht
weil die menschen sagen nein wir wollen
nicht verpflichten wie man hier bleibt
wir wollen hier bleiben zumeist und
sogar die wellen zu mehr gehen und sagen
dass es unsere stadt leider unsere
häuser unsere wohnung gestört aber wir
werden hier bleiben und unsere stadt zu
verteidigen bitte geben sie bitte an uns
waffen dass es eine zeichen stadt eine
panik statt
depression den menschen ist noch mehr
würdig und
bereit seine häuser seiner familie
seinen strafverteidiger also diese april
auch in deutschland in diesem moment an
den bundeskanzler dass ihre mehr waffen
unterstützung braucht und auch die frage
an dich wäre es ein richtiges zeichen
den olaf scholz auch hier her käme wie
der russische staatspräsident die jeder
der dws figur ehe der wichtige politiker
man muss dabei sein muss um eine auch
eine unterstützung weil gemeinsam mit
den starken gemeinsam unter druck hoffen
wir stoppt erstmals oder 14
ich schließe ich nicht aus das ist ein
wird eine
symbolische ironische besuch aber die
noch die aussage dass es ist ziemlich
gefährlich wie schätzt du die lage ein
blending hier für leute die jetzt
hierher kommen wir haben erlebt dass
internationale journalisten angegriffen
wurden ebenfalls ukrainische
journalisten ist gestorben viele
menschen stellen wie gefährlich
empfindest du es hier in kiew momentan
ich glaube es ist mal gefährlicher
passiver das zudem massiv am fernseher
zu sitzen oder nachrichten ließen und
nichts tun das ist viel gefährlicher
diese wird nicht nur in ukraine bleiben
das haben die propagandisten von
verlusten schon gesagt ok ist nur der
anfang diese kriegt kann man ihren
stressigen ist es ganz wichtig nicht
passiv bleiben und aktiv gegen diesen
krieg ich auch noch dazu eine riesige
explosion war der kamera gehört ja noch
ein nächstes werden wir
schon daran über eine messe ist jede
warschau dann schon mal vollgas geben
die situation die ganze cliquen durch
eine wenn eine denkt die krieg ist
irgendwo an resten der betrifft mich
nicht mehr berührt mich nicht dass es
eine falsche vorstellung diese krieg
betrifft jeder in europäische kennt er
das ist die diese krieg kann jeder der
betroffenen in die welt des wegen
gemeinsamer gemeinsamer kraft der muss
an einigen krieg zu stoppen mitteleuropa
und dass das die frage gerade was war
denn ich hab gesagt
gemeinsam wir müssen alles tun betrieb
zu stoppen und eine wieder frieden in
europa bringen präsidenten gefordert
weiter in eine flugverbotszone also dass
keine raketen mehr hier auf eure stadt
fallen was macht das mit euch dass die
heimatstadt kiew so angegriffen wird wir
sind vor ein paar tagen durch die stadt
gelaufen ein bisschen zerstörung gesehen
diesen riesigen krater was macht das mit
euch
das ist eine gesicht vom krieg wogende
zivilisten frauen also wollte sterben
gespräche nicht sogar button war für die
konserven aber das ist das ist eine
horror das ist eine drama drama nicht
nur für gerade drei mal für ganz europa
man muss es ja immer wieder klar war am
tier war vor dem krieg eine pulsierende
stadt tolle restaurants tolle bars lade
mir die in den straßen viel los
wenn man das jetzt die diese beiden
städte nebeneinander die vor dem krieg
und nachkrieg es ist unglaublich noch
vor kurzem hier ist die champions league
finale gewesen mit vasen und vielen
gästen aus ganze welt eurovision song
contest die euro ab 2012 usw das leben
bunter her heute ist die stadt tief ist
fast wie geisterstadt weil mit diesem
motto mit kaffee natürlich kann und darf
man nicht so die straßen gehen es ist
ein ganz anderes bild vor allem auch man
merkt dass dieser krieg diese sinnlose
krieg zerstört war
auf der andere seite motiviert war es
mit wie die ukraine für eigenes land
steigende start zu stehen und zwar nicht
pflichten sondern willkommen das sieht
man auch dass vorher waren weniger
einwohnern tief jetzt werden die
einwohner zu kommen und die kommen jetzt
immer mehr also über zwei millionen
jetzt wieder wie ist das zu erklären
dass wir zurückkommen in dieser ist man
diese dicken und jetzt und hier gerade
während die so viele leute hat seine
kinder familien nach was ich auch eine
gebracht nach außen geschickt und jetzt
die männer kommen zurück bereit sein
statt zu verlieren weil das unsere zu
hause dass es unserer familie haben und
keine wien eine
an sein neues zuhause zu finden und ein
neues leben anfangen dass es lebens viel
zu groß dafür das ist unser land unsere
stadt unsere häuser unserer familie um
unsere zukunft und deswegen ich glaube
gründen nur mir solche sachen heute
kommen wir zurück und
wollte wurde nicht die stadt verlassen
viele deutsche fragen sich immer noch in
diesen stunden in diesen tagen was
können sie selbst machen ich kenne
selbst bücher die jetzt flüchtlingen
helfen flüchtlinge aufnehmen was sollen
die menschen tun
gemeinsame glück für politik der
politische druck für eine wirtschaft nur
wirtschaftsleute stopp einer kampagne
gezogen eine wichtige mission mit
russland weil sie mir gesagt so virus um
investieren das geld statt in seiner
herrschaft und sein erfolg realisieren
das gilt in waffen in mainz das öl und
gas embargo dass deutschland immer noch
nicht machen
alles das ist wir mussten alles die
gemeinsamen touren in den politischen
diplomatischen und wirtschaftlichen
niveau das wir müssen einige
die krieg zu stoppen gibt sehr viel
hinzu und wirtschaftliche politische
militärische instrumente gibt sehr viele
[Musik]
wichtige argumente
was muss man an russland gemeinsam
drücken auch das wird sehr gut ich mag
den gedanken an tausende von menschen in
all die städte in deutschland weil das
zum eine friedliche demonstration
gekommen vor der russischen botschaft
und sagen bitte stoppen das ist wird
auch das ist eine wichtige zeichen also
weiter demonstrieren in deutschland das
ist wichtig wladimir der noch mal die
frage man hat ja das gefühl es
deutschland die sanktion zwar mit nach
aber bestimmte sanktionen dann wieder
nicht will hast du verstehen ihr
verständnis dafür ich werde mal die
klage sagen im westen es ist so dass man
viel redet meistens um wenigsten kommt
wie sehen zerstörte städte nicht nur ein
haus städte diese dritten städte ronchi
ist unzerstört
person und viele andere staaten städten
sind erklärt worden die menschen
tausende von menschen sind gestorben
jede der geschäft mit der uns noch mal
das buch ist auch aufräumen man muss das
stoppen ich weiß das klingt hart aber
unterstützt
diese stimmen unterstützt die
waffenlieferung heute werden den
geschossen heute sterben die menschen
man muss jetzt endlich aufwachen sagen
stopp es ist genug
internationale recht ist gebrauchen ist
es seien kriminelle krieg es ist ein
krieg gegen die nation es ist ein krieg
gegen menschen die leben wollen die
krise holen
gegen das leben deswegen heute muss
gestoppt werden weil noch einmal das
blut ist auf den händen die jeden die
das geschäft mit russland machen weil
ich damit stärken wir die jungs
geschäftssituation und wirtschaft und
die waffen vor allem die heute waren
noch unseren kopf in unseren städten und
zu stürmen einmal das ist nicht das ende
die ukraine ist guter anfang deswegen
ist muss in der ukraine bleiben diesen
krieg muss und so pläne gestoppt werden
um jeden preis ob die politiker kommen
die wurde gekommen die sanktion um jeden
preis heute nach zweiten weltkrieg es
muss gemacht werden und es muss wenig
gesprochen werden es muss zu kommen
klare worte ganz zum schluss war das
immer wieder viele menschen in
deutschland fragen ihr bleibt richtig
für bleibt wie bleiben wir bleiben sie
kommen keine andere wahl das ist
wo sollen wir hin wir
bauen du hast meine wahl du bist ein
ausländer was machst du hier ist es
gefährlich für die ihr nummer wir sind
dankbar dass so wie du wir sind viel
freier journalist und und die
journalisten die gekillt worden ist
seien zeichen weg von hier ist ihnen das
blut und wasser und was ist es super
dass es wichtig dass es wahrheit
berichten weil er den bus und verstehen
das ist media als seine instrumente das
ist auch eine waffe ich telefonieren mit
vielen verwandten mit vielen freunde
liebt in russland sie haben riesige
angst dass es eine totalitäre regime das
ist etwas zu sprechen schlecht zu
sprechen gegen die regierung gegen putin
dass es lebensgefährlich der leute haben
angst um dass ich gesehen dass es sogar
den schlimmsten israelischer zeit ist
noch nie gewesen
weiter zu sagen
trotzdem die
propaganda in russland wirkt und dir der
muster es gibt auch dort mutige menschen
wie man ja zum beispiel die jahren
demonstriert hat wien nimmt die tür und
das stark das ist eine riesige respekt
finden mit allen dankbar die mir und
beim bau der unterricht dann mit solch
zurück nach welt